we have both the youngest and the oldest
people
to have ever flown into space how about
that what a crew do we have for you this
morning
each of our inaugural crew will be
receiving an exclusive
omega watch as a gift which will fly
with them
on their historic flight to space and
each watch will be engraved with their
name
the flight number and a unique blue
origin feather on the back
something to remind them of today's
mission for years to come
this one uh they've donated to me for
the day but
sorry omega you may or may not be
getting it back sorry not
sorry actually uh now these soon to be
astronauts have been down here training
for a couple of days now
and the great thing about new shepard is
since it's autonomous just about
anybody can fly on board we designed it
this way
from the very beginning so the people on
board can sit back
and enjoy the ride of a lifetime let's
take a look of
some of that training from the last two
days this training is meant to get you
comfortable with a vehicle
get comfortable and familiar with the
sights and the sounds
and learn how to maintain a safe mission
again it's autonomous we're not teaching
you how to operate the vehicle
and that's exactly what you're seeing
here you know i um
i actually recently went through this
training and i got to say
the training is a lot of fun very
informative
but also very importantly you really you
build these bonds
with your fellow astronauts and you
create these stories together
now my crew of astrid knots a-s-t-r-o
capital n-o-t-s astronauts
uh we were the fake crew we called
ourselves the prequel penguins
because we were the last rehearsal crew
uh and we wouldn't be flying
but again these are the types of stories
that you walk away with
and uh you know at the end after that
training i felt
prepared to fly and when i say prepared
to fly i felt confident in my own
abilities to participate and enjoy the
flight
but also confident in blue origin the
team
and most of all this big beautiful
rocket that we built with safety
at its core it was a great experience
and obviously one that i highly
recommend
but next time though i'm not stopping at
the training
i'm getting on top of that rocket but
while we have a moment here i want to
acknowledge the entire blue origin team
who has made
first human flight possible so many of
whom are following along today watch
parties
across the country the biggest one will
be at our headquarters in kent there
they are
it is early good morning guys they're
going nuts
already i love it i love it thank you
team blue
you guys are in for an amazing day
amazing day
i love it i'm not really a morning
person but you know what this is a
really good
excuse to get up let me tell you it's
going to be a big day
all right down here in west texas a
little earlier today
our astronauts arrived at the astronaut
training center and standing by
outside the astronaut training center is
our on the ground correspondent
caitlyn dietrich good morning caitlin
what is the latest
good good morning ariane i'm here in
front of the astronaut training center
and i gotta tell you outside here it is
a beautiful day it could not be nicer
for a rocket launch
i'm looking right at the rocket on the
pad here we're all getting a little
emotional and pretty excited
and at about t minus two hours down here
in west texas
the astronauts arrived here they got out
of their truck
and they walked into the training center
i there was not uh
there was no frowns on any of their
faces everyone was smiling
the energy was high wally funk was
basically skipping into the training
center
i think they're going to have a good
flight today and what they're doing
inside is just getting suited up with
their flight suits
and they're going to do you know final
kind of mission briefings just to get
kind of refresher here in the early
morning hours
and then at t minus 45 hours or 45
minutes when they get the go to load
they'll walk right out this door get
into this riven
and be on their way to space thanks
caitlin i
i imagine wally funk was more like doing
cartwheels
into the astronaut training center and i
highly expect her to
be doing the same to the rivian trucks
that woman
her energy is infectious and she has all
the reason
to be excited today as we said she's
been waiting her entire life
to get to space all right we're going to
be checking in with caitlin a little bit
later for more updates
but right now let's turn our attention
to the rocket she's
right behind me just a couple of miles
north from where i sit
now new shepard is named after alan
shepard the first american to go
to space in 1951 61 that is excuse me 50
years ago and earlier this morning as
you can see here
new shepard left the barn and traveled
to the launch pad to prepare to go to
space and back
this time of course with astronauts on
board including our very first paying
customer
oliver damon now back inside the barn
there i should note that we do have a
second rocket
and we have had several paying payload
customers on previous flights
on that rocket we will continue to fly
future payloads
on that dedicated rocket for that the
rocket that's over my shoulder here that
rocket will be dedicated to flying
astronauts this flight and going forward
for many more to come
this day here at blue origin is the
culmination of years of testing
learning and safely proving out the
system across
15 successful consecutive missions with
that in mind let's zero in on new
shepard
the importance of safety and redundancy
and how we got to first human flight
for new shepard we've been following an
aggressive step-by-step approach
from the beginning the first time we
flew new shepard we demonstrated every
single aspect
reentry parachute deployment and that
mission was 100
successful for the capsule m2 was about
rolling in changes and trying it again
this time we stuck the landing but we
needed to show we could do it again
so that was what m3 was for m4
we pushed the envelope lighting the
engine just seconds before it would
impact the ground
we perfected it at that time in m5 we
intentionally
did not deploy one of the main
parachutes
and it worked perfectly we had done a
pad escape test
that the capsule can launch and escape
if there is an accident on the pad
the m6 mission was about testing that
at its most stressing condition we
ignited the salaraka motor in flight
and showed that we can recover the
capsule safely
for m7 what we introduced was a new
capsule design
m8 was just a repeat and then the
third escape test was to show that we
could escape in space
so on m9 the capsule laid off it's a
solid rocket motor
and landed safely m9 and m13
we are flying payload missions for
customers
giving us even more and more confidence
in the capability
of the new shepard system 13 was a
perfect flight
preparing for the m14 issue another
verification and check
we're ready for first human flight
[Music]
i love hearing from our top engineers
like
the architect of new shepard gary lye
who's joined me here at the desk
gary's been at blue origin for over 15
years
and is part of the amazing team that
built new shepard
gary welcome how's it going how's your
day anything going on you got anything
on your schedule
yeah i'm a little busy okay okay fair
enough why don't we why don't we launch
a rocket what do you say
all right let's do it well we got a
little bit of time
why don't we get uh why don't we get
into some of this talk about
um about the step-by-step process that's
gotten us to today so
we talk at blue origin about our motto
gradum ferocitor step by step
ferociously in latin
um talk to us about ns14 and ns15 the
two prior
uh flights with this same rocket what
happened and
why did we finally come to the
conclusion it's time to put people on
board
so ariane the last two flights ns14 and
ns15 you could
think of as full dress rehearsals for
what we're about to do today
we use the same hardware the same
software and even the same operational
procedures
as we're going to use today really the
only difference in today's launch is
that
rather than the astronauts uh getting
out of the capsule at the last
minute um they are going to stay on and
they're going to enjoy the ride to space
so after those those launches we looked
at all the data we made sure that that
hardware that software those procedures
fulfilled all our requirements we didn't
need to change and we came to the
the assessment that yes we are ready
fantastic
now you know again you've been here for
now
17 years i think it is uh you've been
here since the beginning of the program
the the original blueprints the the
requirement building all of that talk to
me about
how you guys approach safety and the
safety philosophy that you took as you
developed and
tested and now are flying this rocket
so we believe this this this vehicle
is very safe and is not just the record
of flight test 15
consecutive successful flight test if it
was just that
we wouldn't be able to prove it the
reason we we
know it's safe is because we have done
so much more testing on the vehicle
and the components on the ground in much
more stressing conditions really what
the flight tests tell us is what
what does the vehicle and its components
have to
what are the normal conditions and then
on the ground we test
well beyond those conditions really
until we break it
so when we say it's safe it's because we
know
it can take much more than it's going to
ever experience in flight
really the flight is kind of easy on the
vehicle fantastic i want to turn our
attention for just a moment to
the the next vehicles in our uh in our
fleet of programs that we've got going
on at blue origin
new glenn and blue moon new shepard
really is at the is is built into the
dna of those programs as well we don't
just stop with new shepard
we're going orbital we're going to the
moon we're going to beyond why don't you
talk about how new shepard
supports those other programs so new
shepard is just a part of the entire
story of blue origin really if you
set out just to make a space tourism
suborbital vehicle you would not have
built new shepard it would be overly
complicated
we selected the architecture of new
shepard so that we could build a vehicle
and technologies
that would allow us to gain practice and
and develop those technologies for those
other vehicles for example vertical
powered landing
it's a very complicated way to land a
vehicle but it is very scalable
and if you are going to a place like the
moon you're going to have to do it you
can't land on the moon
with wings deep throttling engines you
need
that to land on other planets and then
also
liquid oxygen and liquid hydrogen
propellants they're very high performing
the highest performing propellants they
are
and you can also extract them from lunar
water so again
new shepard very important important
part of everything that we're doing here
at blue origin
of course we're going to have an
incredible uh suborbital tourism program
we've got a wonderful payload program
with many
customers who have already flown but
this is just the beginning
of many great things to come at blue
origin now
i want to go back a little bit and talk
about we were talking about safety just
a second ago
talk about redundancy backup systems and
in the case of new shepard backup
systems for the backup systems to the
backup systems the backup systems
what what is going on there because it's
it's it goes beyond what meets the eye
right absolutely so um
every system on the new shepard vehicle
that is needed for safety has
one or more backups many backups in a
lot of cases
so let me give you some examples so
we've already talked a lot about the
escape system
and and and that will activate in case
there's something wrong on the rocket it
will activate and propel the
crew away and land safely we've talked
about the parachutes there are three
parachutes
we've designed the vehicle to land if
only one of those parachutes opens
but that is just to start every valve on
the vehicle every mechanism
every battery every sensor every wire
every flight computer everything on the
vehicle
has a backup and in some cases multiple
backups
an incredibly redundant vehicle last
question for you
would you put your kids on board we set
out
to design this vehicle for anybody not
professional astronauts
anybody with very little training and
that is a very hard problem
and yes we have succeeded and i would
put my own kids on that vehicle
all right one day summer vacation in
space
thank you gary appreciate the insights i
look forward to seeing you back here
later on in the show
and we'll get a lot more input from gary
like and the architect of
new shepard and with that let's take a
breather check out new shepard on the
pad as we take closer to first human
flight
oh
so
all right everybody if you're just
joining us this is blue origins first
human flight we're down here in west
texas coming to you live we are t minus
one hour and ten minutes to go
until jeff bezos mark bezos wally funk
and our first customer from the
netherlands oliver damon
rocket to space and back the excitement
is palpable down here at launch site one
in west
texas but i want to keep things moving
for you so why don't we take a closer
look
at the aforementioned astronauts the
bezos brothers
jeff and mark
do you see the earth from space and it
changes you it changes your relationship
with this planet with humanity
it's one earth i want to go on this
flight because
it's a thing i've wanted to do all my
life
it's an adventure it's a big deal for me
i invited my brother to come on this
first flight because
we're closest friends i really want you
to come with me
would you are you serious i am i think
it would be meaningful
have my brother there i wasn't even
expecting him to say that he was going
to be
on the first flight and then when he
asked me to go along
i was just awestruck serious if you're
willing if you want to yeah
what a remarkable opportunity not only
to have this adventure but to be able to
do it with
my best friend
[Music]
what a cool story brothers sharing this
historic
experience together now mark has been
part of the blue origin story from the
very beginning
he's been with us every step of the way
and we're so excited to see him on this
first human flight you're taking a lot
of us up there with you mark
but we're not stopping there second hue
in flight and beyond
are already in the works and you know
since the auction
on june 12th uh i've had the good
pleasure of speaking on the phone with
many of the participants from the
auction who now have been
quickly filling up seats for the next
several launches
sales are open everybody if you're
interested send us an email at
astronauts
blue origin.com and we're planning two
more flights this year
and as we said many more to come in the
years
following folks this is an authentic
rocket right you're in the crew capsule
launching a hundred kilometers up over
the karman line the internationally
recognized line of space
and safely back to earth and what a crew
capsule it is
let's take a look
[Music]
for your once-in-a-lifetime journey you
will travel
past the boundaries of earth's
atmosphere and into outer space
featuring windows that comprise one
third of the capsule surface structure
the largest windows ever in space
you'll have a view of the curve of the
planet and the vast darkness of the
cosmos
every detail of the capsule has been
precision engineered for your safety and
comfort
with reclining seats specifically
designed to absorb the impact of landing
and an escape motor that can safely
propel the capsule from the booster
rocket
at the apex of your flight you'll
experience weightlessness
unbuckling from your seat you're free to
explore different perspectives
from each window before your return to
earth begins
this is the beginning of a revolution in
space travel
and blue origin is gonna take you there
so yeah our crew capsule is pretty sweet
very spacious i should note that
uh that crew capsule has 10 times the
volume
that alan shepard had on his flight to
space and of course you notice those big
beautiful windows
in comparison to uh to poor allen who
just had essentially a little porthole
to look out of
our astronauts today are going to get an
amazing view
you know today as we mentioned is just
the first of many flights to come
on new shepard for that capsule and let
me tell you as somebody who was
at the recent live auction for the very
first seat on today's rocket
people want to fly to space we had
nearly
7 600 people from 159 countries
registered a bid
huge global interest and uh it was just
incredible to be in the room when the
winning bid was called at
28 million all that money went to blue
origins club for
the future it was it was truly a
stunning day for which we are extremely
grateful
and extremely humbled now for those of
you that are less familiar with our club
for the future you might ask
what is club club for the future's
mission is to inspire
younger generations to pursue career in
stem and to help invent
the future of life in space the club and
its collaborators are doing this in many
ways
like sending student postcards to space
on new shepard and back sending them
posted them
flown in space of course they've also
been establishing
space focused curricula and providing
access to space
on blue origin rockets and just last
week
lords inside to spread the love blue
origin and club for the future announced
that these 19 non-profit organizations
you see on your screen here
will each receive one million dollars
from the 28 million dollars
incredible to see all of that money
being used to help get the next
generation
excited about space why don't we take a
look a closer look at club for the
future
what it is what it's doing and where
it's going
it's my generation's job to build the
road to space
so that the future generations can
unleash their creativity
and one of the things that we have to do
is inspire young people to build
the future of life and space
we're from blue origin we are going to
be sending some postcards to space
the club for the future ask k-12
students
to send us postcards with their dreams
of the future
mine says the future is only a tomorrow
away because if we build the future we
have to do it a day at a time
that's really poetic that's really cool
we're going to send those postcards to
space and new shepard
and then we're going to bring them back
and mail them back to you let's take a
look at some of these
these are fantastic what a great drawing
it's time to verify nice
[Music]
that's beautiful
i'm interested in space medicine and
space exploration so i have a futuristic
city with the rocket launching
thanks for being members of the club for
the future the kids i talked to earlier
if they are representative of the
current generation we are in good shape
[Music]
big things start small
let me tell you the future of space is
in very good hands
guys we're building the road to space
but the journey on it is going to be
yours
and there are a lot of brilliant kids
out there so please keep up the great
work
guys with that why don't we take a
breather check out new shepard on the
pad as
she gets ready for first human flight
all right thank you again everybody for
joining us live from west texas we're
here
at just one hour and two minutes to go
until launch
we are quickly approaching our first
live glimpse of today's astronauts
they're going through their final
preparations with crew member seven
before exiting the training center
and heading out to the launch pad in
their rivian trucks
and now crew member seven is a role that
gets its name from the new shepard
program
uh though today's flight features four
astronauts future flights will take use
of all six seats in the crew capsule and
crew member seven is just that the
seventh member of
each astronaut crew now it's a
two-person role
and here's some footage in fact of kevin
sprough and sarah knights are
current crew member sevens we'll have
that for you in a second here
so sarah and kevin don't go to space
themselves
but they're critical team members that
stay with the crew
every step of the way including as voice
of mission control
to the astronauts during the flight so
it's basically like they're in the
capsule
with our crew and you're going to hear
on today's flight
sarah as capcom or capsule communicator
uh as i mentioned earlier i've gone
through
astronaut experience training and i can
tell you
the crew member seven roles are
essential
kevin and sarah met me as well as the
rest of the crew
that i had during training the evening
that we arrived in el paso texas
and were we were in great hands in their
incredibly competent hands from the
beginning
to the end of our journey down here in
texas so a special thank you to kevin
and sarah
for holding it all together for our
astronauts now i want to introduce you
to another critical member of our team
blue
audrey powers in her new role as the
vice president of mission and flight
operations
she recently joined us here at the desk
for a chat about what it's like
to arrive at this very special moment
audrey uh it's so great to have you here
you've been so important to the
development of the
the company and this rocket and i can
only imagine how are you feeling today
i'm feeling very very excited yeah we
had
an amazing flight readiness review
yesterday and
the team is just so so pumped awesome
well so uh we this is not the first time
our viewers have met you
on the last flight you were one of our
what we call
astronauts spelled a-s-t-r-o-n-o-t-s
um what was that experience like going
through the training and being one of
the astronauts
well i i was actually there working i
was not
just having fun right right right now i
was going through the
training um to really see how it had
progressed over time a number of us did
a review of the training
uh early on and i'll say that that our
training has
has reached such a really great spot for
the astronauts
our human factors team has provided a
lot of input our cm7 team has spent so
much time
really focusing on what is important for
them to first
safely get through the experience and
then just really enjoy
their time up there um yeah so it was
just
it was vetting the entire uh experience
and making sure that we cover the right
aspects of it
right so um uh i also got to be an
astronaut um but i didn't get to do
the uh the next kind of critical step
which is getting inside of the capsule
on top of the rocket
when it's fully fueled fully loaded like
we did during our last
uh our last launch and last webcast
you were one of two you and gary lye
went in there what was that like when
you went in there
and the hatch was closed what is that
feeling like
yeah the the entire tower operation of
astronaut load was just a very
sensory experience and we we walked
through
the sequence a couple days in advance
just to rehearse everything all of the
movements
but on launch day we got out of the cars
and were standing at the bottom of the
tower
and you could hear the vehicle venting
and when you looked at it
there was there was frost coming off the
side like you see sometimes in movies
and it's just this overwhelming sense of
this thing that is waiting to launch and
we're kind of holding it up
you know right so there was a there was
a great sense of urgency that didn't
exist on the days that we
that we rehearsed it and when we got up
and finally ingressed and strapped into
our seat there were a lot of thing it
was it was very mechanical
because of the training that we've gone
through in the simulator and we sat down
and strapped in and it wasn't until then
that you're waiting for the crew to do
the checks and empty out the
the cabin of the various equipment that
you kind of look out and you realize
like how high up you are where you are
yeah and you could feel the vehicle
swaying a little bit
on the launch mount like that that
rocket is ready to launch
um and when it closed i remember
thinking before like i'm gonna have all
these clever things to say to gary you
know because we've worked together for
so long
and like i couldn't think of anything it
was just like i want to go so badly
you know like can you can you lock the
hatch from the inside
we were wondering if you guys were going
to do a little spillway situation sorry
they're cameras i know
yep so it was it was just this this
really
rich sensory experience being in there
from all angles
yep well so uh you are now head of new
shepard
flight admission ops what does it feel
like this day that we're
actually putting people on board and
we're closing the hatch and we're
keeping the people
in the castle go to space and back what
does that feel like well
um we we've spent in recent weeks we've
finalized
a year's long effort called our human
flights certification
plan and it culminated in an extensive
review
um you know over the last month with
external reviewers
and our faa partners were involved and
it it's kind of it was the culmination
of
the entire program you know years of
work on this program and i was so struck
by how much work has gone into this
across
the years and across the disciplines and
the the people in that room kind of
finalizing all of these check boxes
it was it was just an overwhelming sense
of the history that we had collected of
this program
um and i was so i i before i
i came to this position in new shepherd
um i supported new shepherd
um and i i knew the hard work that was
going on in this program
but i have been so so struck by
just the professionalism and the bias
for action
and just the critical thinking that
everyone on this program
puts in and i i have been awestruck by
people that i have been working with for
years i mean i knew
i knew what great work they did but but
being part of it
and part of this team i'm so honored
that they
um you know wanted me in this position
and and then i'm
participating in this now audrey to you
and to your team to the whole blue
origin team thank you for all of your
hard work we cannot wait to see
the launch and um you know godspeed new
shepard thank you i can't wait to see it
either
audrey offers such great insight into
new shepard
she's also a pilot herself oh and the
chair of the commercial space flight
federation she's had
an incredible impact on space
legislation and policy in some major
ways
as well as a major impact on blue origin
so thank you to audrey
she's kind of busy today so we're uh
we're very proud to have had her on
stage just a couple of days ago
all right we're at t-minus 55 minutes to
go until
launch let's go ahead and check out new
shepard as she gets ready for her flight
today to space and back
with our first human flight crew
uh
um
so
thank you everybody again for joining us
live from west texas
for blue origin's first human flight we
are at t minus
52 minutes to go until launch right now
our four astronauts are inside the
astronaut training center
we are waiting for them to exit to get
in the rivens
and then we will be waiting for a go for
astronaut loden
i can already hear the helicopter above
that's going to be
following them on their way out now that
astronaut
training center what we have in that
training center
is basically it's a classroom but i'd
say the centerpiece of it
um is a beautiful crew capsule simulator
and it's a really cool simulator
some of you have may have seen in the
past we've had a a mock-up that we've
been able to take
to various events but the simulator
that's in the astronaut
uh training center is kind of a a step
above a step beyond
because in it we are able to simulate
the sounds the vibrations the uh
full crew screen and alert system that
we have
for every single seat and so during the
training
you spend a lot of time of course
understanding with crew member 7
understanding
the general new shepard system all of
the procedures
ingress egress and and
getting to know the the lord team but
you do spend a lot of time in that crew
capsule
and as mentioned we we go through these
simulations of the flights
and of all sorts of different scenarios
so that our
astronauts feel comfortable as we said
so they can sit back and kind of enjoy
the ride enjoy this incredible
experience they've got these huge
windows right next to them we want them
to be focused on that view
focused on feeling the g's as they come
on you know you're in these beautiful
nice soft
uh reclined seats that disperse the g's
it's a wonderful experience and that
simulator
we run these scenarios we've got full
audio
we've got full vibration and it's it's a
it's a really critical component of the
the training program let's say
now uh we also of course we will take
them out
to the pad the day before launch we want
them to
walk up the uh the crew access tower uh
you'll see
uh it's hidden a little bit in that shot
there on the left there but that
is the safety shelter so we'll see as
the astronauts drive out
to the pad itself they will ascend the
stairs the senescers on the left
they'll take kind of a bit of a time out
in the safety shelter
the crew member seven kevin sprough will
go out
to the across across the bridge there to
the
uh to the tower that's in the center of
your screen he will be working with the
tower crew there
make sure everything is set and sorted
to go for astronauts
he will then go back to the uh to the
safety shelter and get
the uh the astronauts and get them
ingressed
into the capsule the astronauts right
now though they are
in the astronaut training center again
we are waiting for them to
emerge shortly here we are t minus 49
minutes to go
until launch again they are going to be
uh entering into the the rivian trucks
and heading out to the uh
out to the training excuse me out to the
uh the launch pad this will be our first
glimpse
of the astronauts we're going to see
those shining smiles of them
of theirs i'm sure they're trying to
contain their
excitement you know you've got that that
excited
energy that of course they're they they
are controlling themselves
although again let's be honest wally
funk doesn't control her
her excitement i'm as i said fully
expecting her to do
uh uh full full uh somersaults and uh
and cartwheels on her way into the
rivens
and why don't we just wait here for a
moment as we wait for those astronauts
to
emerge
okay
thank you again everybody for joining us
live for new shepard's first
human flight we are waiting for our
astronauts to emerge from the astronaut
training center
we've got the uh we've got our on the
ground correspondent caitlin dietrich
who is just outside of the training
center caitlin what's going on out there
so you can really feel the energy start
to build now we've just heard that
everything's continuing nominally
towards launch the countdown is
is moving forward we've got our
helicopters in the air
waiting to capture our astronauts as
they take their rivians to the launch
pad
the sun's coming up it's a beautiful
morning our teams are going to be
standing on the road hooting and
hollering as
the astronauts drive by on their way to
the tower and i'm starting to get goose
bumps over here it's a little bit
emotional but
we'll be back in just a couple minutes
and uh we'll watch these astros as they
head out into their truck and on their
way to space
fantastic thanks caitlin we'll uh send
it back to caitlin in a moment here as
we wait for those astronauts to
emerge from the astronaut training
center you know i'll tell you
the last thing that they do before they
exit the training center
is there's this special uh coin ceremony
it's a
challenge coin that's given to each one
of the astronauts
for them to take in their suit up to
space and back
it's a it's a military tradition but
what's it really makes you feel like you
are
part of a team um and what a team to be
part of what a crew
to be part of only new shepherds
astronauts are going to be able to get
these coins you only get
you only get the coin if you get to go
up to space and back and these
astronauts again have completed their
their training and they
are ready to become the next set of
international
astronauts so again we're waiting here
for just a moment
while we wait for the astronauts to
emerge from the astronaut
training center we are at t-minus 46
minutes to go
until launch
um
okay
um
oh
so
we would like
thank you again everybody for joining us
live for new shepard's first human
flight we are at t-minus 45
minutes and here the astronauts come
there you see jeff bezos in the
foreground
oliver damon stepping into the riven
crew member seven kevin's strobe there
on the right
as well as wally funk what a moment for
her
at the age of 82 she will become the
oldest astronauts who have ever flown
into space
and there she is loading into the riven
while he was part of the mercury 13
program back in the 1960s
the program to train women to go to
space that ultimately was canceled but
now it is her moment
today is an incredible day for her
all right now we're going to be waiting
for mission control
to get a go for astronaut load out to
the pad
that's when they will the rivian will
start
heading out towards the pad they're
actually going to pass right behind me
here i'm certainly going to give them a
wave
they then will pass mission control
get some last minute love from uh from
our team there as well as their families
and then they will head down the road to
space to the launch pad
and we'll go for loden there they go
everybody
what a moment you can probably hear our
team already losing it down here we are
super excited
and there they are
high fives from everybody what an
incredible moment
they're coming over here just behind my
right shoulder
a moment we've been waiting for here at
blue origin so much hard work has led to
this moment
how exciting wally funk the bezos
brothers
oliver damon our four crew members are
heading out to the launch pad there they
go
see you guys oh my gosh they are in for
the flight of a lifetime
and just a couple yards to my left here
that is mission control and here they go
passing by mission control
there you see jeff bezos waving to the
team
and they're gonna hang a left there
as they head down the road to space
now while we watch them travel down that
road to space they've got just a couple
of moments
it's a long two mile road there we've
got a couple of moments why don't we
meet
aviation icon wally funk
you're in zero gravity for four minutes
you come back down
we land gently on the desert surface
we open the hatch and you step outside
what's the first thing you say
i would say honey that was the best
thing that ever happened to me
[Laughter]
[Music]
i've been flying forever and i have 19
600 flying hours i have taught over 3
000 people to fly private commercial
instrument flight engineer airline
transport gliding
everything that the fa has i've got the
license for
and i can outrun you
back in the 60s i was in the mercury 13
program
they asked me do you want to be an
astronaut i said yes
they told me that i had done better and
completed
the work faster than any of the guys
so i got a hold of nasa four times
i said i want to become an astronaut but
nobody would take me
i didn't think that i would ever get to
go up
nothing has ever gotten in my way they
said wally you're a girl you can't do
that
i said guess what it doesn't matter what
you are you can still do it if you want
to do it and i like to do things that
nobody has ever done
we're going to fly you up into space on
the very first flight
that's your i can't tell
people that are watching how fabulous i
feel
we've been picked by you origin to go on
this trip
you're gonna be an astronaut oh finally
you'll love every second of it
ha ha i can hardly wait
[Music]
we are just so thrilled and frankly
honored
to help wally funk finally realize her
dream
of going to space now recently i was
lucky enough to spend
a couple of moments with her right here
at the desk why don't we take a look
molly it is a pleasure to meet you
as a fellow pilot you are an inspiration
so thank you you don't know how great it
is to meet you
that you are a pilot i don't want you to
go fly more in that glider and then
jumping oh that's great and hopefully
follow in your footsteps and go on new
shepard one day
absolutely i mean so wally you've you've
waited a while to go to space um
that's silly question but are you
excited no not me
of course i said since i got on the
airplane and i got to fly the airplane
and get here and meet all of you this is
so fantastic
on so on launch day what do you think is
going to be the most
exciting thing what are you looking
forward to the most
lift off climb undo
and be able to move around in the if if
there's room
i want to do a lot of stuff because i've
done that in in other situations
and you were just telling me a second
ago you're going to take your camera up
there and you've got a postcard
that you're going to take a photo with
that is what's going to be on the window
when i go up
and then i'm going to take a picture of
it with earth behind me
that's such a beautiful photo of you
and the american flag back there in your
flight suit
and um that's going to be a spectacular
photo so
you know this is probably i imagine your
first time down here in west texas at
our launch site absolutely what do you
think
i used to be in texas and and teach
i i think everything's fantastic i mean
i've been created so well
and the food is so great i can't believe
it's coming from
uh i don't know california right right
and and you're lucky to be here with all
these friends and the people and
and and see what's going on absolutely
well
so wally as i said you've been an
inspiration to me uh
what would you say to the next
generation of
of young people that are out there that
want to go to space well i've talked to
young people
all my life how many of you girls and
boys
want to fly well not many raise their
hands i said well i tell you what get
your parents
to take you out and give you a flight
right that's what i
my parents did as seven years old and
if you like it you'll continue on and if
you don't
you might continue on because
something's to be in your
heart that's going to want you to do
that i cannot wait to see you go to
space
thank you for being with us it's a
pleasure to have you thank you thank you
honey
so yes as you just saw wally funk is the
real deal i was doing
my best to contain my fan girl moment
there because she again is an
inspiration to so many people
around the world and myself included we
see here that the astronauts
are starting to ascend the crew tower
there's wally wavin
she's leading the crew gary welcome back
it's good to have you back here at the
desk to get you to help with the
play-by-play here
we just saw a moment ago uh that they
drove around the ring road
stopped took a photo because of course
you know you got we were gonna we're
more memorializing this moment as best
we can for these astronauts they so
deserve it
so going up the tower we've got wally
then it looks like jeff bezos
his brother mark and oliver damon
that are heading up to their rocket now
while we have a moment here i do
understand that caitlyn dietrich is
standing by at
mission control what's going on outside
mission control caitlin
hey guys caitlin here i'm with jarrett
jones the head of our new glenn program
here
jared how you feeling today watching the
launch here from mission control
excited awesome this is amazing it's
just incredible
you could only dream about this day and
you know what katelyn
it's not lost on me and probably many of
the viewers that today is like july to
20th
the day neil armstrong who also
graduated from my alma mater
boiler up uh stepped on the moon
and uh made history and we're doing it
at
new shepard and blue origin doing our
first human launch and
it's just amazing and the reason i'm
excited but also focus is that
there's quite a bit of technology
transfer from new shepard to new glenn
everything from the be3 engine with the
uh
the locks and the hydrogen all the way
down to
our landing gear i mean this is an
exciting day for us
and i'm just excited i don't want to
take the uh spotlight away it's about
new shepard
and uh i'm just very proud of this team
and then blue origin as a whole i mean
just amazing
just amazing day caitlyn well we like to
say that new shepard is basically the
second stage of new glenn so you're kind
of seeing the second stage fly here
today absolutely
absolutely new shepard was built and
designed
for scalability and we took advantage of
it in new glenn so
it's amazing amazing feat that we're
doing and just
proud to be here just glad to be here so
smart it's the epitome of our
step-by-step approach as you hear us say
and i want to pan back to mission
control we've got a lot of our team here
on the porch here hey guys
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we are so excited we saw the astronauts
fly by here just a second ago
and right in that room is some of the
world's most brilliant
engineers flying this rocket today and i
don't know about you but i'm starting to
get a little bit emotional
um so back to you ariane and we'll see
it we'll see you after launch
thank you caitlyn enjoy the launch jared
jones enjoy the launch
everybody out there uh outside of
mission control as well as in mission
control enjoy the launch
uh you know gary we talked about it a
little bit earlier
caitlyn touched on it just a second ago
how basically new shepard is being
scaled
up to new glenn tell me how
you've thought about that because you've
you're part of obviously new shepard the
architect of new shepard but you've been
part of thinking about
the broader road map if you will that
blue origin has
that's right new glenn is is a scaled up
version of new shepard it does use
a different main propulsion for the
first stage but the second stage of new
glenn
that engine is a derivative of the new
of the be3 engine that's flying new
shepard
today um and the techniques for vertical
landing which we perfected with the new
shepard vehicle are going to be applied
to the new blend vehicle we have very
high confidence
that the very first launch of new glenn
will stick that landing on the ship we
would not have that confidence
without the new shepard program
absolutely absolutely and
jarrett jones again who leads that
entire new glenn program
he uh he has a a big job but he's gotten
a lot of help he's kind of gotten this
catapulted help
from the development and now the the
operations and flight of
new shepard i should note that new glenn
will also carry humans one day
we build all of our programs from the
very beginning with the intent
to put people on board and talking about
astronauts in people
we just saw them enter in to the
astronaut safety shelter
i would like to highlight one thing
which is uh you know
wally was saying that she could she
could outrun you she was the first up
those stairs and first in the astronaut
shelter so she
no lie that uh that wally funk she uh
she's got quite a bit of energy
you know people she's 82 but i'm
convinced every time i read that that
it's a typo
that she's actually 28 because again
that woman
all right gary why don't you tell us a
little bit about what's happening in the
shelter because we should remind our
viewers that on
the last flight that we had we basically
did a full up
rehearsal of what we're doing right now
you were part of that
uh of that astronaut crew that we had
what happens in the shelter so
the shelter is has two main functions
it's a shelter in case of
of some kind of emergency if they need
to evacuate the capsule very quickly
they can
go across the bridge very only about 75
feet and be in this shelter very fast
it is fireproof it can handle a whole
set of anomalies that might happen with
the rocket
you see those blue tanks against a wall
the shelter has its own breathing supply
air breathing supply
in case of a fire outside it also has
communications they can talk directly to
capcom from there
right now they are just waiting for the
go-ahead from the pad crew
that is preparing the capsule to start
astronaut load
fantastic and you see there in the
foreground in the black suit that is
kevin sprogue our crew member seven
as well as wally funk seated on the left
soon to become the oldest person to have
ever flown in space
then going clockwise here oliver damon
soon to be the youngest person to have
ever flown in space at the age of 18 he
comes to us from the netherlands
a special shout out to our intern
international viewers especially those
in the netherlands hello everybody you
should be very proud
of your countrymen there then we have of
course mark
bezos brother to jeff bezos our founder
in the cowboy hat he is a uh he's he is
a
a true texan as at heart you know we
call it the ranch down here
we like to incorporate that into uh into
a lot of what we
of what we do in the spirit that we have
down here at our launch site one
all right they are leaving
the uh astronaut safety shelter here
let's watch as they prepare to cross the
bridge
what a moment jeff bezos
mark bezos
wally funk
and oliver damon ring the ceremonial
bell
making some noise on their way to get
into the crew capsule
kevin the crew member 7 that you see
there in the black suit
he is now going to help them ingress
get into the capsule get situated in
their seats
and uh of course help them get buckled
into their harnesses and go through any
final safety checks before closing the
hatch i mean
we should note though gary and i again i
have both been through the
astronaut training experience it's a
five-point harness by the by the time
you're done with training
you can do that upside down backwards
with your eyes closed
uh inside and out i mean you you
definitely understand how
uh how that works and you're going to
need to because when we come back
you want to get back into your seat from
zero g that's very important
let's watch here as they cross the
gantry taking some final photos
we've got our photographer there felix
coons
a brilliant photographer who's taken
those uh those beautiful shots of the
crew that we saw earlier
and there they go into the crew capsule
gary do you want to talk about uh the
the hosing and the piping that you see
going into the hatch
so that is just a cabin environmental
control system
while it's on the pad before we seal the
hatch we want to make sure
the air is fresh and air conditioned in
there
that that hose will be removed obviously
during hatch closure
and so what they're doing now is just
one by one entering
the cabin and getting getting fastened
and uh
then they will go through a series of
comments with capcom
fantastic there's wally funk in seat
number three there
oliver getting situated in seat number
one
i'm starting to shake a little bit i
not only again have we practiced this
and not only on the last
flight did we have a full astronaut
reversal like this
but it's different we've done again 15
consecutive
missions to get to this point but it's
so much different
when you put people on board but again
so much testing so much design so much
thought an incredibly well-trained
blue origin team that's supporting
these these astronauts our first crew on
new shepard
just wonderful we are ready for today
now we are standing by here for capcom
to welcome our crew
in to the capsule let's stand by for
some audio there there's our mission
control
and sarah knights
sarah knights again as she has this
incredible i have you live in clear
seven how me
here comes kevin kevin will help you out
here it comes wally
it i can see it it stands in there don't
don't keep pulling on it
so again we've got capcom sarah knight
she's one of our crew member seven on
the left
our four astronauts are loaded into the
capsule
there is wally funk in her seat
as well as mission control talk about
how about locked and loaded these
this team is really i mean you've been
in emission control
during during these launches what is
that like
so at this point in the procedure
everybody is incredibly focused they're
true professionals
they are they're looking at the data
following procedures there's really no
distraction
you can hear a pin drop in that room
unless they're working an issue
and as you saw in that in that picture
we run a very very tight ship here
at blue origin and on the new shepard
program that
that picture of the front room emission
control that
is all the people that are operating the
rocket at this point
in terms of pushing the buttons to make
things happen in addition to the pad
group
there you see we've got crew member
seven that is uh making sure
wally's harnesses are all tight and snug
there
no to your point about crew gary i mean
we talk about
designing an autonomous vehicle that
launches and lands and re-reuse but
we've built also the operations
to also complement that to lower the
cost of accessing to space because
that's
that's at the heart of of building this
road to space so we've built it
so that it's an efficient vehicle
efficient operations
absolutely so in addition to that front
room
which is really just a half a dozen
people and some backups to relieve them
in case
in case they they need a break there is
an engineering back room
right behind that room it's it's the
size of a small conference room really
and it consists of engineers that are
there just in case there's an anomaly
that needs investigation
but but you can actually see it through
those back windows that's it
that is all that is needed to launch the
shepard we have some support staff
on call in uh washington state in case
of an anomaly but for the most part
that's it and we architected it that way
so look oh yeah catch did you say
ketchup
she was waving at you gary and is that i
think that's the uh that's the postcard
that she promised everybody she was
going to be bringing up to space with
her
so not only is the crew ready but uh we
got the props ready we've got we've got
the photo shoot all set up
but getting back to uh to the the crew
and crew operations that we've set up as
you said
lean and mean but also we talked about
it earlier in addition to the safety and
critical to safety are
redundant systems backup systems back up
to the backup
and uh you know we were talking about um
the team that we have back in kent so
that that is part of it
it's not just in you know let's say the
mechanical systems the engineering that
goes into the capsule but
from an operational standpoint we've
built that from the very beginning
some beautiful shots there of the
capsule
so the window with the the white square
there that is
uh that is wally funk to
the left
that is uh that is mark bezos
jeff bezos's brother
and in fact to the left of him a little
harder to see off of that other window
uh that will be jeff bezos and
oliver damon on the other side of the
hatch
he's also uh harnessed in
ready to go to space ready to become the
youngest person to have ever flown in
space
again he comes from the netherlands so
beautiful again as we talked about at
lordran we really want to
we want to open up this experience to
the world and it's so wonderful
that he is not just representing the
next generation but also
more flags as we fly to space
standing by here from capcom new shepard
this is blue origin mission control
good morning astronauts and welcome
aboard the rss first step
let's get things started with the comm
check astronaut oliver how do you read
through control as an over louder copy
astronaut wally how do you read me
wally push the button
press the button until you can hit your
good oh
this is astronaut demo i have you loud
and clear
it's my honor and my pleasure all right
astronauts we are at t-minus
21 minutes and counting as we proceed
i'll keep you updated
for now just sit back and relax
fantastic and there you heard it all
four astronauts
are ready to go to space they just had a
quick comms check
with sarah knights on capcom one of our
crewmember seven there
uh you've heard all four astronauts are
jazz you know wally there was i i'm sure
she's a bit distracted again we've said
this before
she has waited over 60 years from the
days that she was part of the mercury 13
program
to go to space that program to get women
into space was cancelled
but you know what she is uh canceled no
more everybody she is going to space
such an honor to be able to help her
realize this dream
of going to space after so long what i
mean what a what a
what a moment what a woman that uh
that really personifies perseverance
and and pushing through it all right and
here we go we are closing the hatch
gary do you want to talk a little about
what happens when you close the hatch
obviously it's a pressurized vehicle
what does that mean with regards to uh
to closing the hatch there
so the hatch has a double seal on it
there are two sets of seals
so what they're going to do when they
close the hatch to make sure it is
properly sealed
is they're actually going to pull a
vacuum in between both of those seals
and make sure that vacuum doesn't decay
and that checks the integrity of both
seals fantastic
now i understand that we've got caitlyn
dietrich again on the ground
we've got an update from her caitlin
what's going on
she is uh she is just she's
almost ready so let's let's hold off on
just a moment
for our update from uh from caitlin
dietrich in the meantime let's watch
here as the uh
the tower crew continues to
close close the hatch make sure that the
the pressure seals are all all ready to
go there we see
mark bezos giving the thumbs up there's
jeff in the background
waving what a what an experience to do
with with your your siblings your your
best friend what what and what a day
for this four crew gary you uh
you know we mentioned again that you
have gone through the astronaut
experience
you uh you went through it uh actually
here we go i think we've got
caitlin just a moment gary hold that
thought caitlyn what's going on out
there mission control
hey everyone so basically we've actually
left mission control the porch
and now we're at what we call fallback
three it's on basically the entrance to
the road to space
and right here is where the astronauts
drove by they went all the way to the
tower you can probably see it there in
the very distance
here we just closed the hatch and
everything's looking nominal and
basically what's going to happen is
once the parish or excuse me once the
capsule is under parachutes
we have a convoy here right behind us
that's going to be racing out to get
that hatch open
and celebrate after their victorious
flight to space
so that's what we're all preparing for
here after their 11 minute flight
so we're pretty excited wonderful thank
you so much caitlin for
that update gary uh so
you as we were just closing out that
question so on the last one you actually
were in the capsule
right you and audrey powers who we
talked to a little bit earlier in the
show were in the capsule
when they closed the hatch what does it
feel like at this moment
it's actually quite tranquil
after the excitement and all the
helicopters and and
ingressing and that adrenaline you have
a moment in the capsule now to reflect
when when the hatch is closed it's
actually pretty quiet you've got your
hearing protection and just in case you
can still hear
um capcom but you have a moment to
reflect the fact that you're
seated reclined in a seat next to a
window directly next to a window that is
so big
you can just turn your head and feel
like you're floating
right on the edge of the rocket and then
we've designed it that way so that when
you're actually in space
you don't have to turn your head you
look right out and have this sensation
of
actually being out and it also kind of
adds to the voluminous feel
of the the capsule we said earlier it's
10 times the volume that alan shepard
had on his flight but
but it's it is big and the windows make
it look big that light acoustic
padding make it look big and then once
you're floating up there in
in space over the karman line in zero g
it kind of adds a
third dimension to it yes we wanted that
spaciousness we wanted that sensation of
floating
really if we were able to do it we would
have made the entire capsule transparent
that that is kind of a cool idea is that
for the next iteration you're working on
that
is that in secret all right we're not
going to release those information on
our webcast but stay tuned everybody
all right we're going to toss it back to
capcom i understand that we've got a
special message from
uh christina bezos sister
to jeff and mark bezos
first step blue control on that note
jeff and mark i have a special message
from you for your
from your sister christina
steve and i are so excited for this
monumental launch
jess this is something you've dreamed of
your whole life and your passion for
space is infectious
mark you're the best champion when it
comes to encouraging us
in our adventures as you buckle in i'm
reminded of when jeff was captain kirk
mark you were sulu and i took the role
of lieutenant uhura
we would battle klingons while firing
torpedoes
all the while dodging in and out of
traffic and praying that we make it to
our destination safely
mark be prepared to fire those torpedoes
if ordered to do so
now hurry up and get your asses back
down here so i can give you a huge hug
we love you and godspeed new shepard
and there it is beautiful message from
christina
there is our kent headquarters
going nuts as they should a big day for
our full
blue origin team
it's early out there on the west coast
but they wouldn't miss it for the world
look at them
[Applause]
so amazing again what a day for the
entire
blue origin team for these crew members
that are on board
for their families that are here that
have been supporting each one of these
people's dreams to go to space
just incredible and uh you know we are
sitting here at t-minus 15 minutes to go
until launch
we are in a brief holds here but why
don't we
meet oliver dayton one of those
astronauts again
our first very very first paying
customer
and soon to be the youngest person to
travel to space at 18.
let's see oliver i think it's the
ultimate dream for so many people to go
to space i guess my first memories of
space
were thunderbirds i was a big fan of
that
watched every single episode there was
that was like the big thing with like
the rockets and everything
oliver is this your first look at the
vehicle yeah it's so good to go with
this group because wally is like one of
the best pilots ever and has such an
amazing life story
of course jeff is one of the best
businessmen ever and a great visionary
and mark is a firefighter and is such an
amazing track regulator of his life
i feel a responsibility because i'm the
youngest in space and to get more people
interested in space
and not even just space but science will
be such an opportunity for me to do
when i touch down and i get out of the
vehicle i think i'll
just speechless
now oliver also has his pilot's license
and will be studying physics in college
and in just a bit he'll officially be an
astronaut but uh gary
did you talk to oliver i did i had an
opportunity to meet him
did you start recruiting did you did you
get on that
what are you doing sitting here come on
man we were like that that guy not only
going to study physics but also
innovation so we can only
you can only imagine what is in store
for oliver in the years to come but i
can tell you what's
what is in store for him in the next
couple of minutes here he is going to go
to space
over the carmen line up 100 kilometers
up
the internationally recognized line of
space and he is going to come back
a freshly minted astronaut cannot wait
for that
now we are at t minus 15 minutes to go
until launch
we are in a brief hold here and while
we're in a hold why don't we turn it
over
to new shepard and watch the rocket as
she gets ready
to take these four astronauts to space
and back
good
is
thank you again everybody for joining us
live from west texas we are
here at t minus 15 minutes to go until
launch
we are in a brief hold we've got our
astronauts that are loaded
into the capsule you saw there just a
moment ago we had oliver damon on the
left
in the left window to the right of the
hatch is our founder jeff
bezos coming around around him
is mark bezos and on the opposite side
of the capsule
is wally funk and again we're just here
in a brief hold but while we have a
moment let's throw it back to the pad
and catch out some of those shots of our
astronauts as they get ready for
their flight to space and back this
morning
please
so
thank you again everybody for joining us
live from west texas for new shepard's
first
human flight we are at t minus 15
minutes we are in a brief hold here
this is okay i mean to say gary you can
appreciate this we spend
we spent years designing this rocket
months and months designing the mission
and if we need to take
a couple of minutes more to make sure
that the team is aligned
that we're all set and sorted that our
astronauts are happy
that the weather both on the ground and
up aloft is
within green zones then we're going to
do that how do you guys think about
holds when you're in mission control
what is happening right now
there's really two kinds of holds there
might be hold while they investigate an
anomaly
and very often that is not the case
though um there are sometimes holes just
to catch up with the timeline
the thing about new shepard that's
distinct that from several
from orbital vehicles that you might
have seen is that we don't need to
launch at a precise time to meet
some some launch window because we're
trying to intercept something in space
we have a lot of time we can take our
time it's better to pause
and and hold if there's any reason to if
there's a sensor reading that you want
to investigate
or you just want to catch up in time so
that's why we tend to take these holds
otherwise we bias to launching as soon
as possible so we don't otherwise have a
lot of
buffer in in the normal count absolutely
so again
the uh well actually now i understand
the hold is lifted yeah so it sounds
like
uh that we have gotten the timelines all
aligned our teams are all sorted
and we are continuing our countdown why
we have a moment here again let's throw
it back to the pad
check out our astronauts in the castle
as they get ready for their launch to
space and back this morning
all right everybody we are t minus 14
minutes
and five seconds to go until launch here
can got goosebumps going already that
again adrenaline is building and the
energy is building up here as the clock
ticked down and uh while our astronauts
and our teams are going through the
final checks with our crew member 7 and
the launch team
let's talk about seeing earth from space
and how it changes you and
we're very fortunate here at blue origin
to have several nasa astronauts that are
working with us
and they've logged hundreds of hours in
space and they offer
a keen perspective on what our first
human flight astronauts
are just minutes away from experiencing
i find it's very interesting that people
can look at a picture of earth taken by
an astronaut
but they don't get that change inside
that actually being there in space gives
you it is one of those things that you
you kind of have to do the perspective
from space is a really fantastic one
you you can see things that you never
thought you'd see from earth
it really can't help but change your
life it changes your perspective
having that kind of an experience makes
you feel
smaller you really do come back with a
sense that the earth is a
closed environment everything we have
here to
eat breathe drink it's all traveling
together
and looking at the blackness of space
and looking at the surface of the earth
and seeing that almost nothing separates
those two
all of humankind is on this one small
rock
protected by this thin fragile little
layer of air
it makes you realize that the planet is
in fact a giant spaceship
traveling through space that's home to
seven billion of us
and i think every astronaut who goes to
space is changed by it in some way
they've actually documented a change in
core values
in almost all astronauts from before the
flight to after the flight
and as millions and millions of people
begin to get this experience
i think the knowledge on earth a
different understanding about our planet
will gradually occur
the experience is something that that
changes who you are
on the inside it's very powerful it is
so memorable and so unique
that that people walk away speechless
[Music]
incredible stuff i i hope one day i get
to experiencing
experience that and i know obviously the
four people that are on top of that
rocket are about to do that
gary do you want to talk to us a little
bit about today's uh flight profile how
they're getting up to space over the
karman line and back home down here to
west texas
absolutely so t minus zero is the the
time
that we actually gary if you don't mind
standing by i understand that we are
uh ready for our go no-go poll
this is the flight director new shepherd
is go for launch booster commence
terminal account
we'll go flight controller strap uhf
voice
enabling onboard
all right thank you everybody for
joining us again uh sorry about that
so we were we got so caught up in uh in
the flight profile and and that
uh and the perspectives from our nasa
astronauts we just caught the tail end
there of the go no go pole
um but i'm hearing that we're uh we're
looking good for flight today so
let's get back into that flight profile
gear that you're telling us about here
again how are they getting up to space
over the carmen line the internationally
recognized line of space and then
back down here to earth in west texas
okay so t minus zero is actually not the
point of liftoff it's when we
send the command to start the engine it
lifts off about seven seconds later
it will ascend um for about two and a
half minutes
um and and then shut off it's it goes
through what we call miko main engine
cut off about 20 seconds after that the
capsule will separate and that's when
the fastened seat belt
uh light on their panels will will
turn off and they'll be able to float
around the capsule for
three to four minutes um during that
time
um the the both vehicles are still
ascending and they will ascend above
100 kilometers to common line today
where we're headed for about 100 506
kilometers
um and and then start d they're decent
um
the capsule the booster will actually uh
re-enter first it's
it's more aerodynamic before it hits the
the atmosphere it deploys
wedge fins on top to stabilize it
um and then uses those aft fins um to
steer back
uh over the pad just over the pad about
20 000 feet above it deploys drag brakes
to slow itself down
and then restarts its engines just
seconds before hitting the ground to
slow itself down to a soft landing
the landing legs will come out just
seconds before landing it might do
one or two uh maneuvers to make sure
that it's over that pad
um and then it will touch down softly
meanwhile the capsule
will will continue its flight um the
astronauts will strap back in
before hitting the atmosphere get back
in their seats
they'll be thrusters that will stabilize
the capsule just to prevent it from
rocking too much and then parachutes
will deploy about
10 000 feet above the ground first drugs
will fire and those will extract the
mains
and then finally a landing will occur on
a cushion of air
which will fire just about six feet off
the ground
fantastic and you know we've mentioned
this before on previous webcasts
that uh the uh the dirt down here it's
like talcum powder it
goes everywhere and so when we have that
air cushion that fires it really kicks
up the dust
but again they're coming in at just
about one or two miles an hour it's a
really nice
soft landing and uh again gary we
confirmed we are
go for launch for first human flight on
new shepard
my goodness i mean you've been waiting
for this day
for 17 years since you joined blue
origin what what are you feeling right
now gary it's still hard to believe that
it's actually here i don't know if it's
set in yet but
the main thing i'm feeling is i'm
thinking about the entire team
past and present the hundreds and
hundreds of people
that have worked on the new shelf
program and what this must mean to them
absolutely it's uh you know we talked
about
about the team here we it's a it's a
lean and mean team
obviously but each one of those people
has contributed
so much to this program it's uh again a
special shout out to
all of our blue origin team members
watching around the world
now uh for the others that are watching
around the world
uh if you want to experience
space flight for yourself if you want to
do
what jeff and mark and wally and oliver
are doing today
and you're serious about it send us an
email at astronauts
blue origin.com we are open we're open
for ticket sales to send you all
to space what just an incredible
incredible day
and uh you know it we we
we're so lucky to have this particular
crew
on board today gary and i feel like
um you know not only do we have this
beautiful story about
uh the bezos brothers that are going up
and wally and and oliver soon to be the
oldest
and the uh the youngest astronauts who
have ever flown in space
oliver that's representing our
international
uh friends out there taking the uh the
dutch flag to space
you know and then again wally who has
been thinking about going to space well
her entire life but certainly
since the 1960s and she was part of that
of that program that got canceled and
she just kept you know just kept
fighting
until uh until recently we said hey
wally want to join us for this
first crew and i can only imagine our
future customers that are going to go on
board they're going to represent the
world they're going to represent many
different backgrounds and we certainly
look forward to that as we mentioned
we're going to have two more flights
in 2021 for a total of three and again
many more to come
in the future and that's that is just
fantastic and i can imagine
again as you were building the system
gary as you were thinking about
okay this is not just a just a one or
two flight
you know operation with new shepard
you've built it for
for a long term program we've built it
to continue indefinitely
and and to take hundreds and hundreds of
astronauts in the future
we hope to be into the thousands soon
and just think about that right there
have only been about
560 570 people that have
ever been over the carmen line over up
100 kilometers up over the
internationally recognized line of space
and today we're going to add four more
to that list which is so
so so cool yeah since someday in the
near future we will be over 570 just on
the new shepard program
can you imagine uh you're going to go up
absolutely you're going to go up with me
you win man awesome okay we are t minus
four minutes and 20 min
20 seconds to go until launch what an
incredible moment let's check out
new shepard on the pad here we are
waiting uh
the the rocket is going to go into some
last minute checks on the vehicle at
t-minus two minutes
is when the vehicle we throw the show
over to her
it's it's all on her it's an autonomous
vehicle but gary do you want to talk to
us about
what are some of those last you know
last minute checks that the the vehicle
is going through
and that we're going to see especially
on our screen right so as you mentioned
the last two minutes are
auto sequence and that is executed
entirely by the vehicle itself
through an automated checklist you'll
see a couple of things
there will be things that you don't see
such as sensor checks
pressure checks on the tanks
radio checks all hundreds and hundreds
of different checks will be stepped
through in this checklist but what you
will see is the hydraulic system
spooling up
uh which will wiggle the engine gimbal
as well as the app fins
um those they're not only wiggling those
surfaces but they're making sure that
there's no stiction and they travel
smoothly fantastic and again we are
waiting to see that you'll be able to
see uh as gary said you don't get to see
all of those last minute checks but we
certainly get to see the
aft fins as gary mentioned those are the
fins at the base of the vehicle there
are four of those
uh obviously they help direct the the
rocket both up and down
and then the the engine will gimbal that
is our be3 engine
the blue engine three a hundred and ten
thousand pounds of thrust
liquid oxygen and liquid hydrogen are
what uh are the propellants
in the engine it's uh not only a
powerful
and also throttle-able engine the
throttle i'll talk about the throttle
ability just here for a second we
throttle the engine back as it comes
back to land
and that's what creates a nice soft
landing because as it comes in
of course it's not filled with all the
propellant that it had on the way back
up so we throttle it back kind of like
an airplane it comes in for a nice
soft landing and you know
what what a trip to space and back again
this vehicle
uh we've had 15 successful flights on
again we're looking forward to this 16th
one of course a very special one
with people on board today
i just two minutes there we go
you're just retracting the bridge is
retracting
there's oliver on the left jeff bezos on
the right
we are about to go to space everybody
[Music]
we are in auto sequences
[Music]
when that engine gimbal check occurs and
that engine swings they should actually
be able to feel it
in the cabin because it'll sway the
stack back and forth
there go the aft thin checks
[Music]
there you see the engine gimbal check
just peeking out at the base of the
[Music]
rocket
all right here we go everybody thousands
of people contributed
years to this historic moment ladies and
gentlemen
it's time for blue origin's first human
flight godspeed
first crew of new shepard let's light
this candle
t-minus 16 guidance internal
t-minus 10 9 8
7 6 5 four
command engine start two one
[Music]
go jeff go marco wally go oliver you are
going to space
oh my goodness listen to the roar of the
be3 engine we are just about to pass
through max q
maximum dynamic pressure that was when
the stresses on the vehicle are at their
maximum
max cube max q is confirmed
beautiful burn on that be3 engine
hydrogen and liquid oxygen as the
propellants it's a nice
not just clean in terms of beautifully
performing but
what comes out of it it's steam right
to see to see the the the glow of the
of the engine underneath the rocket just
under our shoulders and to know
that we've got a crew that is going to
space
it it just feels different doesn't it
gary
it is totally different
all right you can follow along of course
the speedometer in the bottom left
the altimeter in the middle of the
screen there
so far appears to be a nominal flight
all right coming up here on mikko main
engine cutoff that will be followed
shortly by separation and at that point
after separation we're gonna uh let the
astronauts
unbuckle and take in the freedoms of
zero g there is miko main
engine cutoff a beautiful shot
down the new shepard rocket look at that
view
unreal
awaiting separation here
and here we are you can start to see
stand by you're going to see the
separation of the capsule from the
booster itself
oh
wow
and there we go our astronauts have
passed the carmen line
at about 328 000 feet continuing their
ascent
you see the two vehicles there
when the speed hits zero you know that
they've hit apogee their
maximum altitude and you hear they're
having
quite an experience
okay
you just have to wait for it who wants
the skittles
one minute warning one minute warning
okay
it's dark up here
check
[Music]
blue control all of her palace perfect
got the astronaut wally
wally no control
got the astronaut demo
copy astronaut days out
copy
thank you again everybody for joining us
live for our first even flight on new
shepard so far a nominal flight our
booster is about to return
to its landing pad there we see engine
relice
that is sonic boom
oh and
booster touchdown welcome back new
shepard
a beautiful rocket that provided a
beautiful flight
to
what space up your booster has landed
blue controlled based on the screen and
there it is our crew capsule with our
our four crew members on board you have
a very
happy crew up here i want you to go
stand by drugs stand by job
stand by maine stand by me
oh so far a nominal flight here comes
the crew capsule
back from space the drogues deployed
here the mains out reefing and coming to
full inflation
our rocket went over mach 3 and now
they're coming
floating back down at just about 15 or
16 miles an hour
about to join us home back here in west
texas
after having gone over the carbon line
the internationally recognized line of
space
the world's newest astronauts
gary how you holding up friend i i'm
speechless
wow and those big beautiful windows
i've just got about a minute and a half
of
floating before the activation of the
skirt yet to
for a for a soft touchdown at this point
um there are sensors on board that are
detecting how high they are above the
ground
multiple sensors and just six feet above
the ground that
that cushion of air will will puff
and they will have a soft touchdown
almost like just sitting in a chair
but i'm sure their adrenaline is pumping
and touchdown welcome back
new shepherd's first human crew
what a flight first step congratulations
to all of you
all of you oh what a day
what a day
oliver thank you so much for everyone
there was amazing
it was amazing
copy first step you have a very happy
capcom here as well
let's do a status check astronaut oliver
status correct copy
i am unbelievably good
coffee
flute controls bezos best day ever
yeah copy everyone
go ahead and remain in your seats crew
member 7 is on their way
shortly you will hear the capsule
off-gassing
my main mission
your apogee was 351
210 feet
[Music]
um
all right that was incredible chloe
i was surprised at how easy zero g was
yeah
yeah it felt it felt very like
remarkably natural
well what a day you can see our four
that the world's new newest minted
astronauts
are there on board discussing their
incredible flight of a lifetime
up to space and back wow
our team is now preparing uh landing
safety operations
the recovery crew has already uh
well minutes ago has left the barn there
to go
open the hatch you can see them there
they're arriving at the capsule
in the riviens you can actually also see
that the parachutes
fell very close to the capsule it means
that there's not much wind out there is
a beautiful beautiful day
not too shabby gary what do you think no
it was picture perfect
and and it sounds like it landed pretty
much exactly where we predicted that's
how they can get to it so quickly
they start moving even before it landed
based on
on the prediction of landing um we use
weather balloons that we launched
throughout the morning and that that
gives us a very good idea of where it
will land which are within a thousand
feet
uh what you're seeing that they're doing
um right now is is kevin sprough
crew member seven is just making sure
everybody is okay and gives them a
thumbs up
um they're also grounding the vehicle
when you go into space
you could accumulate pretty significant
electric charge
that's actually why we prefer that the
astronauts not get out
themselves so that we can ground the
vehicle of static charge which can be
quite strong
excellent and i think there that kevin
sprogue our crewmember seven has given
the uh
given the thumbs up uh for all of our
our uh
our astronauts that are on board there
again jeff bezos mark bezos
wally funk and oliver damon
what an incredible day you heard them on
the audio best
day ever i mean this is this
i feel like this is our best day ever
and we didn't even get to go up to space
i mean what a day again congratulations
to the entire blue team our astronaut
crew and of course the friends and
family
of these uh incredible astronauts that
are just about the exit
the capsule here let's wait for that
moment there you see jeff in the window
felix is up here
yes
you're just moving one of the main
parachute lines to make sure it doesn't
snag the hatch when it opens
there's jeff thumbs up
cc safe jimmy
[Music]
oh
go to the camera
[Music]
gary the architect of new shepard
congratulations to you man
congratulations give me a hug this is
just
oh what what a day again thank you
everybody for joining us live
for our first human flight of new
shepard
our four astronauts went to space and
back topping over
350 000 feet well over 100 kilometers
they've come back down safely
we're just waiting here for egress our
crew
is going to get out of the capsule and
meet their families back here on the
ground of course their families
that have provided so much support since
they were little kids and
dreamt of this to this day and this
moment
get in here
family are we ready
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
congratulations
[Applause]
what a day again here a successful
launch and landing of the new shepard
rocket and crew capsule with our
first human flight crew there jeff bezos
mark bezos oliver damon and wally funk
and their families there giving big hugs
all around what a moment so much emotion
from all of them the the elation did you
see wally
did you see wally when she came out you
know this i told you she was just she
was probably gonna do a summer
you know cartwheel as she came out of
that capsule
what an incredible incredible day
let's just capture a couple more moments
of this again
space flight so much engineering so much
objective hard engineering technical
thought that goes into it but when you
put people on board
there's such an incredible emotional
component to this
the the the time the effort the blood
sweat and tears
you know this better than anybody else
again congratulations gary thank you
ariane
and congratulations to the entire blue
argent
this might have looked easy today it was
anything but easy
to design a vehicle like this that is so
safe
that anybody can get on board from wally
funk
who today became the world's
oldest astronaut at 82 to oliver damon
who became the world's youngest
astronaut at
18. he joins us from the netherlands
again big shout out
to our viewers in the netherlands
congratulations you should be
very very very proud of your countrymen
i mean again in representing the next
generation
of people that are going to go into
space i mean i can't wait to see
what oliver does with his future i can
only imagine you heard him in the video
you know he he just wants to spread
spread the love spread the message that
i can't wait to hear their impressions
of
the you know the view from up there and
in fact i hear in just a moment we we
hope to be getting a couple of
impressions from our astronauts we'll
stand by
for that there you see
the friends the family you see our ceo
bob smith there
you see a couple of our other executives
of course this crew
safety team and it's champagne time
[Applause]
everybody
[Applause]
it's the only proper way to end the
space flight exactly the only proper way
to end
a space flight with a champagne shower
and man that is let me just tell you
that is the beginning
of the celebrations there is a lot more
to come
we are again not just the crew and the
families but
everybody at blue origin who has made
the historic day possible
[Applause]
oh there's a big hug from jeff to wally
funk
the oldest person in space you
a beautiful moment thank you
for a woman who uh was
denied her opportunity to go to space in
the 60s she had to wait to the 2020s but
man it was worth the wait
there you see the bezos brothers hugging
it out
oliver damon you saw him earlier giving
his father a big hug
what a moment he saw the first hug when
jeff came out of the capsule
to his mother jackie followed by his
father
mike i mean
again what what a day what a day
to the thousands and thousands of
members of team blue you contributed to
today as well i know you are all hugging
it out back
in kent washington at our headquarters
near seattle
sending you guys a lot of love from down
here in west texas
what a moment
i mean granted you know gary we weren't
in the capsule
but my favorite part was hearing you
know the hooting and hollering
and the laughing you know jeff is known
for his big boisterous laugh
i mean he is uh he's having the moment
of a lifetime here and you can only
imagine as they were floating around up
there
you saw them say gosh look at look at
the views
[Applause]
[Music]
gary is this as you had expected it 17
years ago when you joined blue origin
you know we we like to blue and blue we
like to you know
start at the end goal work backwards to
make the design
and then and then build and then build
forwards
when you sat there 17 years ago with
this
with the very small team at the time at
blue
is this what you would imagine it's
certainly what we hoped for
but with the size of the team when i
joined blue origin there were only 20 of
us
in the warehouse and it would have taken
a huge leap of faith to think that we
could have gotten to this point but we
have
just just incredible uh you know
i've been here seven years we were 300
so man you got me beat by
by a lot there but you know i can
remember when we
when when i joined the team and we were
talking about
this the moment the day that we were
gonna fly people
you know you talk about it but it's here
and it's now and i remember
we were talking about okay well what
will this video look like and what will
that video look like
it doesn't compare it doesn't matter
this is this is
real this is so much better than
anything that that we could have
ever imagined the the again the
emotional component to human space
flight we've had
15 consecutive test flights which as you
said earlier
is why we knew that it was we were ready
to put people on board this
this this rocket and that's what led us
to today
to know that we could do this we could
do this safely and to give people
the experience of a lifetime and i think
based on uh
based on what we see there i i think you
know job well done sir
job well done and not only did we do it
today we can do it again
and again and again and again precisely
absolutely love it that was amazing
everybody i want to thank you all for
joining us from around the world
for today's blue origin historic first
human flight
it's been a moment for the ages and
guess what
we're just getting started we've got two
more flights this year
and several more in the coming years i
want you to join us a little bit later
today we're going to have a live press
conference on our website
you're going to get to hear the
first-hand impressions from
our four astronauts that went to space
and back
but to all of you out there if you like
what you saw and you are serious and
interested about reserving your seat on
a future rocket ride to space on back
with new shepard
we've got some exciting news for you we
are open for ticket sales
send us an email astronauts at blue
origin.com
we can't wait to fly to space and back
gary
it has been an honor to share the desk
with you today
uh the architect of new shepard thank
you so much for your insights thank you
so much for all of
your hard work and all the hard work of
your team that has
made today possible thank you aryan it
was unforgettable
absolutely the the road to space is
being built everybody and we took
a huge step today but we also need your
help if you're interested
in learning more about blue origin or
joining our extraordinary team
please visit our website and if you'd
like to commemorate today's historic
launch we
also have some mission patches for you
there and that's also where you can get
some apparel some collectible
gear it is all there look at that sweet
patch
so beautiful with the names of our of
our new astronauts
what a day everybody my name is ariane
cornell
thank you so much for joining us it has
been a pleasure and an honor to be your
host
and of course until our next launch
gradum ferocitor
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you